oh là là c'est sale môme mais il
m'énerve à sauter partout ses enfants
très vite les jeunes filles reprennent
leur sujet de conversation préféré
ah ouais le fraise là il est pas mal du
tout une fraise pour Alexandra c'est un
beau garçon par contre il a pris un coup
de soleil levain faut lui dire de mettre
de la crème solaire un écran de contrôle
pour éviter les dérives sur les réseaux
sociaux la loi visant à encadrer les
influenceurs a été adopté à l'unanimité
hier soir par 194 votants à l'Assemblée
nationale un tournant majeur pour les
150 000 influenceurs recensés en France
le texte prévoit entre autres
d'interdire certaines pratiques comme la
promotion de la chirurgie esthétique
elle a posté ça sur Instagram elle se
trouvait trop petite et voulait et bien
avoir plus confiance en elle donc elle
mesurait un mètre 70 désormais elle fait
1m84 on appelle ça l'allongement la mise
en avant de produits contenant de la
nicotine ou encore empêcher la publicité
pour les pronostics sportifs en cas de
manquement les peines peuvent aller
jusqu'à deux ans de prison et 300000
euros d'amende
146000 euros au total et elle explique
d'ailleurs elle détaille tout ça 112000
euros pour les deux opérations 14000
pour l'ablation des deux ongles 12500
euros pour la kinésithérapie par exemple
et 3000 euros pour les médicaments
nous sommes donc le premier pays du
monde à légiférer sur l'influence
commerciale avec des règles des
obligations et des protections
la fraise à ma droite là-bas bracelet
rouge mission abandonnée
l'expression brasse les rouges signifie
qu'il a moins de 18 ans au camping c'est
la règle tout le monde portant un
bracelet jaune pour les adultes et rouge
pour les mineurs
une étude ouais ça paraît dingue une
étude réalisée par des chercheurs de
l'Université de Stanford aux États-Unis
montre qu'à partir de l'âge de 13 ans le
cerveau des adolescents subit de
nombreux changements neurobiologiques et
il n'est plus disponible à la voix de
leur mère ils préfèrent se concentrer
sur des voies inconnues c'est un
processus d'adaptation qui prépare les
adolescents à leur indépendance
cette image est un peu floue et de loin
on peut avoir l'impression que cette
dame est en train de déposer un colis
dans une consigne et bien pas du tout
cette femme est en train d'abandonner
son bébé ça se passe à Séoul c'est un
pasteur qui a imaginé ce dispositif tout
simplement parce qu'en Corée du Sud les
mères célibataires sont totalement
rejetés par la société
[Musique]
courir après les rats le papa tortue et
la maman tortue tortue et les enfants
tortues
le bébé est entré au centre de façon
surprenante
sa mère la déposée dans cette niche
accessible depuis la rue et maintenu à
température constante
la baby box
e
son nouveau-né dans la boîte une alarme
se déclenche et on peut venir le
récupérer au plus vite et moi je sors
tout de suite pour retrouver la mer et
tenter de la convaincre de nous laisser
ses coordonnées c'est une vidéo qui
donne un aperçu des différents terrains
sur lesquels les policiers de la
préfecture peuvent être amenés à
travailler une vidéo qui correspond
totalement au code Tik Tok il y a de la
musique il y a des plans très courts il
y a même quelques effets vraiment une
vidéo qui correspond au code
c'est assez AB all cops arbasta ça veut
dire tous les flics sont des bâtards
c'est encore pire que ce que je pensais
ok les filles sont des bâtards c'est
hyper violent
on leur demande pas de venir à nous mais
on va pour montrer ce qu'on est avec
plus de transparence avec un message qui
est plus ludique plus accessible alors
effectivement pour parler aux jeunes
TikTok et sans doute le meilleur moyen
c'est le réseau social le plus prisé des
16 24 ans d'ailleurs cette idée elle est
pas tout à fait nouvelle puisque la
police nationale voilà c'est ce que vous
voyez et sur TikTok depuis 2021 et un
monde plus d'un million d'abonnés sur
son compte
Vision 2 en fait bien sûr et en fait
sont très à l'écoute sont très gentils
quand je vais faire l'intervention mon
jean ou mon pantalon se lève faut le
voir
au début je montais un peu je disais que
c'était les lettres de mendeles musk
vivre dans le numérique a annoncé avec
fierté avoir reçu l'accord des autorités
sanitaires américaines pour implanter
des puces dans les cerveaux humains
c'est un premier pas important qui
permettra un jour à notre technologie
d'aider de nombreuses personnes parce
que moi je suis pas d'accord avec ce que
vous dites quand vous dites qu'il est
plus intelligent que nous non
précisément et ce poème en est la preuve
il est minable votre poème il y a aucune
pierre il a été les plus chiant
conservatrices de vos auditeurs mais pas
du tout je voulais rentrer dans la
modernité je prends un témoin tout le
monde il est mécanique hier elle devait
prononcer un discours de politique
générale ce qu'elle a fait avec des
phrases plutôt convenues comme nous
avons travaillé dur pour assurer un
avenir solide au Danemark ou bien encore
je suis fier de tout ce que nous avons
accompli blablabla bla bla bla en fait
ça c'est pas intelligible c'est
mécanique c'est minable le poème que
pardonnez-moi
il est mécanique exactement c'est assez
le dictionnaire des rimes il y a rien il
y a pas de souffle bien sûr mais bien
sûr que y a pas sauf qu'au bout d'un
moment et bien elle s'est arrêté et elle
a révélé que tout ce qu'elle venait de
dire et ce n'était pas l'aile ni de ses
collaborateurs c'était un discours
entièrement écrit par chat chipiti
l'intelligence artificielle disponible
gratuitement depuis novembre et la
première ministre a commenté ce texte
n'a pas toujours mis dans le mille la
ponctuation n'était pas parfaite mais
c'est tout de même fascinant et
terrifiant et c'est bien ce qu'elle
voulait faire alerter sur cette
technologie qu'elle trouve à la fois
révolutionnaire et dangereuse Michel de
Drucker dans une vidéo partagée ce matin
sur son compte Instagram l'animateur de
Vivement Dimanche 80 ans donne de ses
nouvelles après avoir été réopé du cœur
en mars dernier il se dit en pleine
forme et annonce son retour à l'antenne
en septembre prochain d'abord on lui dit
bonjour c'est une des écoute je sais
qu'il nous écoute chaque matin mais je
j'ai déjà raconté la petite blague parce
que je te regarde chaque matin mais il a
dit la même chose à Bruce tout ça
[Musique]
oui parce qu'en fait on avait fait une
petite émission sur BFM à la suite de
son premier communiqué où il disait
qu'il allait bien et il m'a appelé parce
qu'il voulait absolument que je lui
donne les coordonnées de tous les gens
qu'elle travaille sur l'émission parce
qu'il voulait tous les remercier un par
un il y a failli avoir deux mariages
dont l'un avec avec
très déprimé
on voulait réunir nos solitudes et on
avait un petit peu bu donc j'ai dit oui
il a dit oui tout le lendemain
est-ce que vous vous faites du sport
extrême
d'un niveau pour qu'on en bourse